some of our nation's leaders joined the
family of harry reid in downtown las
vegas today to say goodbye to the former
senator he died last month at the age of
82 after a long battle with pancreatic
cancer david charns is live outside the
smith center tonight to take us through
today's memorial service david
all is quiet out here at the smith
center right now but of course many
powerful people were here earlier today
all honoring a man who went from the
back roads of southern nevada to the
halls of washington
[Music]
from a humble start in searchlight to
the hallowed halls of washington former
nevada senator harry reid is remembered
as the quiet guy who got things done did
my dad ever hang up the phone on you
without saying goodbye
reed's five children
[Music]
personal friend carol king and two
presidents among those painting a
picture of a senator we didn't always
see you know he said you've been working
hard and do doing a lot of the right
things to be democratic leader but you
need to dress better please buy some
better shoes
devotion to his wife of 62 years landra
and his story of working his way from a
rural town to congress
all echoing through the smith center
something about harry
he never
gave up
he never gave up
he never gave up on anybody
he cared about former president barack
obama eulogizing reid saying he could
not have passed his landmark agenda
without him the senate and the country
benefited from your extraordinary
leadership
and i could not have asked for a better
truer
friend sure did love you back
when you come back
tell me what did you see
the killer's front man brandon flowers
saying he and reid had a shared faith
and desert beginnings recalling this
moment from a visit to the capitol he
had me sing the nevada state song
in the office
and
i think he was showing me off a little
bit but i also as we've all heard today
i think he just he loved where he was
from
and one of reid's son saying in the
service that it was actually brandon
flowers and the killers who reed wanted
to hear in terms of music in his final
days now going from here reed will lie
in state at the capitol in washington
d.c on wednesday and we learned today he
will be buried among family in
searchlight we're live outside symphony
park tonight i'm david charns live local
now